hi my name is Cara Bay and I am a
professional actress living and working
in London in the United Kingdom today I
have had the pleasure of training at
really amazing establishments such as
the Royal Academy of Dramatic Art and
the Sylvia Young Theatre School and I've
also had the pleasure of selling out
really amazing visits here in London
such as the King's Head Theatre Arcola
theatre and pleasant theatre and so
today I'm going to be providing general
advice to other actors about how to
learn lines really quickly how to choose
your maybe first headshot photographer
and also how to earn more money to
facilitate your acting career
firstly I know that learning lines is
probably the most boring and possibly
even stressful part of an actor's job
especially when you have less than 24
hours to learn a script or in my case I
know I have had to learn 18 pages of
dialogue and I was given the script at 8
p.m. ish in the evening and then had to
audition at 11 a.m. the next morning in
a Persian accent and I didn't even know
what a Persian accent was and let alone
how to do it so yeah I think generally
there is some ways that I know I do in
order to help learn lines really quickly
and efficiently so firstly I think
actors should always be reading like
whether this is books plays magazines
newspaper articles you know the free
newspaper in the troop just because
every every time you do that you are
really strengthening the muscle muscles
up here because you're retaining all of
that information in such a condensed
amount so then when you're actually
faced with a script a whole new
different piece of text those muscles
are stronger and are more stimulated so
it's kind of easier to absorb that those
lines more quickly and then also the
second part of reading for character
preparation so basically I'm quite I
will read everything in order to get in
to character for a role so this might be
radio pieces recounts diary entries if
I'm doing something really historical or
anything really like at the moment in my
room at home I have a newspaper I have
them fashion magazines from Russia like
replica ones because I was trying to get
into character for a Russian teenage
girl like last week so I have that and
if you're kind of more engaged with the
world you're trying to create I don't
know the lines kind of sink in a bit
easier and you're cut because you're
owning them you're owning them in your
own way and you just are more connected
to them the last way I like to learn
line
is by focusing on movement memory and
muscle memory and just kind of trying to
challenge myself in to kind of think of
how many ways I can learn my lines and
get that into my body so that could be
by whispering them shouting them singing
them writing them all the way out doing
them in as many different accents as I
can and doing them as if I'm talking to
a child or like a really really old
person just so I am getting it all the
way into my body so that my body will
know how to do the lines when my mind
forgets or I'm really tired and can't
forget
next I'm going to be talking about head
shots so head shots are like their size
and they're really important because
they get you in the room so first piece
of advice like I understand they're
really expensive for what they probably
are but really do not scrimp on head
shots and so when you're going about
photographers just remember that you
know a casting director or a director or
producer or whoever will be casting from
about a hundred thumbnail images all
tiled
on a computer screen so if your headshot
doesn't have your eyes sticking out on
top of them and you know they can have a
massive screen full of so many people
then I mean you're probably not gonna
get cooled in like sorry
so yeah and it was so secondly when you
are choosing your headshot photographer
please remember to exhaust all of your
research methods please simply don't
just Google headshot photographer and
then whatever your city or town is
because chances are yeah I mean that
might be good but why don't you actually
go on to an agency website of actors who
were actually booking jobs and have a
look at their headshots and you know are
they interesting are they engaging do
you want to put them in a room then
probably save that save all of the names
of the people that interest you and then
choose whoever you want really
and then next I'm gonna talk about when
I go into a headshot photographers
website okay they might have loads of
famous people they've taken pictures off
which is great they're gonna have them
first because that obviously looks great
for them but did the famous people
actually look like you because remember
that when you're purchasing headshots
you don't know in advance what they're
gonna look like so you've kind of got a
really estimate what you might end up
with at the end of the day so if I'm
looking at a website if I see loads of
male actors that are really famous and
standing out I'm probably gonna be a bit
like mmm well I don't really see females
so I can't really estimate how myself it
could be
ants so yeah just bear that in mind and
also bear in mind the fact that a
fashion photographer is amazingly
different from a headshot photographer
so you know you're not a model you're an
actor at the in the day so just bear
that in mind when you're choosing your
headshot for dog fur
lastly if you're young in your career
like perhaps me and you're thinking how
on earth am I gonna afford all of these
amazing headshots to get really amazing
conditions to also learn mindful I have
some money advice for you because we all
need to do something I think on the side
so you probably have a job already but
you know that job doesn't stretch to
extra classes extra plays trips to
Russia to get into character or Russian
museums to get into character so firstly
I want you to kind of think about doing
something like writing or freelance
writing or blogging because a lot of
actors currently do this and they
actually have blogs where they tell
people about what they do and also share
their skills and expertise in their
fields but a lot of factors don't
actually use Google Adsense or a similar
kind of system to put adverts on their
sites and make more money
out of it that way so I guess that's
something to kind of think about because
it's pretty money and you're not really
doing anything in order to get the money
so just think about it that way and also
I know that quite a lot of actors share
skills so that can be teaching that can
be I like to run workshops for little
kids like I get paid to do that and for
me that's just fun because I don't
really think of it as a job I just get
to like hang around and play games with
like kids and watch them act which is
really really fun and also I know actors
that share whatever skills they have so
accents languages musical instruments
skills practically anything and you can
also you work whenever you want flexible
hours which is great when you've kind of
got auditions rehearsals classes filming
all of that like you can just money when
you can and lastly I just want you to
kind of think about that you can
practically do anything for money so you
could be a hair model you could drive
for uber you could be
a delivery driver you could be one of
those people that get paid to literally
take documents from one building to
another there's so many different ways
and really just research and have fun
with it